เราทุกคนต้องการความสามารถในการสื่อสารข้อมูลส่วนตัวโดยไม่กลัวว่าใครจะดักฟัง แต่การออกแบบ
ระบบที่ป้องกันได้อย่างสมบูรณ์แบบนั้นไม่ใช่เรื่องง่าย ในตอนวันนี้ของ Qiskit in the Classroom เราจะพูดถึงว่า
สิ่งที่เรียกว่า quantum key distribution สามารถ
ช่วยได้ยังไง ยินดีต้อนรับกลับสู่ Qiskit in the Classroom ในซีรีส์นี้เราจะครอบคลุมหัวข้อที่คุณอาจพบใน
คอร์สมหาวิทยาลัยที่เกี่ยวข้องกับการคำนวณควอนตัม แต่ละวิดีโอมี interactive module ลิงก์อยู่ในคำอธิบาย ดังนั้น
อย่าลืมเช็กดูนะ วันนี้เราจะเข้าสู่ขอบเขตของ quantum cryptography การเข้ารหัสคือการศึกษา
เทคนิคสำหรับการสื่อสารที่ปลอดภัย สิ่งนี้มีความสำคัญมากต่อหลายส่วนในชีวิตของเรา ทุกครั้งที่คุณใช้
รหัสผ่านเข้าสู่เว็บไซต์ ส่งการชำระเงินแบบดิจิทัล หรือเมื่อรัฐบาลส่งข้อมูลทหาร ทั้งหมดนั้นทำ
ผ่าน protocol การเข้ารหัสบางอย่างเพื่อให้คนดักฟังไม่สามารถรู้ความลับของเรา แต่มีความตึงเครียดอยู่นะ
เราจะมั่นใจได้ยังไงว่าคนที่เราต้องการสื่อสารด้วยสามารถเข้าใจข้อความของเราได้ แต่ไม่มีใครอื่นสามารถทำได้
ในอดีต นักเข้ารหัสได้คิดค้น protocol หลายอย่างเพื่อพยายามทำให้ข้อความของพวกเขาต้านทาน
การดักฟังได้มากที่สุดเท่าที่จะทำได้ บางครั้งสองฝ่ายที่ต้องการสื่อสารอย่างปลอดภัยตกลงกัน
เกี่ยวกับรหัสล่วงหน้าที่หวังว่าจะซับซ้อนมากพอที่คนดักฟังไม่สามารถ crack มันได้ แต่
อย่างที่คนอย่าง Alan Turing และนักถอดรหัสในยามสงครามคนอื่นๆ ได้แสดงให้เราเห็น แม้แต่รหัสที่ซับซ้อนที่สุดก็สามารถถูก
crack ได้ ในอุดมคติ เราอยากส่งข้อความที่เข้ารหัสในวิธีที่ไม่มีรูปแบบเลย
และไม่มีทางที่คนดักฟังจะเข้าใจได้หากไม่มีคีย์สุ่มลับที่มีเพียงผู้ส่งและ
ผู้รับเท่านั้นที่รู้ แต่นั่นทำให้เราเปิดรับช่องโหว่ใหม่ เราจะส่งคีย์นี้และมั่นใจได้ยังไงว่า
ไม่มีใครดักจับมันได้ ในปี 1984 Charles Bennett และ Gilles Brassard ได้คิดค้น
วิธีส่งคีย์อย่างปลอดภัยด้วย quantum bit ซึ่งตอนนี้เรียกว่า BB84 คุณสมบัติหลักของ quantum
bit หรือ qubit เหล่านี้ที่ทำให้ protocol นี้เป็นไปได้ คือมันเชื่อฟัง uncertainty principle คุณไม่สามารถวัด
ระบบควอนตัมโดยไม่รบกวนมัน วันนี้เราจะเริ่มด้วยตัวอย่างของรหัสการเข้ารหัสง่ายๆ แล้วฉันจะ
แสดงให้เห็นว่า quantum key distribution และ uncertainty principle สามารถทำให้เราใช้การเข้ารหัสที่แทบจะถอดไม่ได้
ฉันจะพาคุณผ่าน BB84 protocol อย่างละเอียด และสุดท้ายเราจะรันมันบนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมจริงๆ
ก่อนอื่น ให้เริ่มด้วยเกมที่คุณอาจเคยเห็นมาก่อนที่เรียกว่า cryptogram
คุณได้รับลำดับตัวอักษรที่ดูสุ่ม แต่โดยใช้ความรู้เกี่ยวกับรูปแบบใน
ภาษาอังกฤษ คุณสามารถแทนตัวอักษรหนึ่งด้วยอีกตัวเพื่อให้ข้อความมีความหมาย นี่คือตัวอย่าง นี่คือ
ข้อความลับที่มี substitution cipher ง่ายๆ ดังนั้น R ทั้งหมดแทนตัวอักษรหนึ่ง M แทน
ตัวอักษรอื่น และอื่นๆ ถ้าอยากลองแก้ด้วยตัวเองก็หยุดวิดีโอตอนนี้ได้เลย
ปรากฎว่าข้อความนี้ถูกเข้ารหัสโดยใช้ cipher ง่ายๆ ที่เรียกว่า Caesar cipher ที่
ตัวอักษรแค่ถูก shift โดยจำนวนหนึ่ง ในกรณีนี้คือ 9 ดังนั้น A กลายเป็น J, B
กลายเป็น K, C กลายเป็น L และอื่นๆ ยิ่งข้อความยาว ก็ยิ่งง่าย
ที่จะเห็นรูปแบบ ดังนั้น ด้วยข้อความที่ยาวเท่ากับที่เราได้รับ Caesar cipher หรือ cipher อื่นๆ ที่
แค่แทนตัวอักษรหนึ่งในตัวอักษรด้วยตัวอื่นก็ค่อนข้าง crack ได้ง่ายๆ วิธีที่ปลอดภัยกว่าในการเข้ารหัส
ข้อความลับคือด้วยที่เรียกว่า one-time pad ด้วย one-time pad คุณสามารถมี shift ที่ต่างกันสำหรับแต่ละตัวอักษรใน
ข้อความ คุณแค่ต้องบอกเพื่อนว่า shift เป็นเท่าไหร่ในแต่ละตัวเพื่อให้พวกเขาถอดรหัสข้อความได้
รายการ shift นี้เรียกว่า key หรือ pad เรียกว่า one-time pad เพราะใช้ครั้งเดียวแล้วทิ้ง
ถ้าใช้มากกว่านั้น รูปแบบจะเริ่มปรากฏซึ่งอาจทำให้การเข้ารหัสสามารถถูก crack ได้ ด้วย
การเข้ารหัส one-time pad ทั้งข้อความที่เข้ารหัสแล้วและคีย์ต่างก็เป็นแค่ string ของ nonsense สุ่มๆ แต่
เมื่อเอามารวมกัน คุณจะเห็นข้อความลับโผล่ออกมาจาก noise
มาทำตัวอย่างสั้นๆ กัน สมมติว่าฉันได้สร้างและส่ง one-time pad นี้ให้เพื่อนแล้ว ซึ่งมักเขียนเป็น
binary และแล้วฉันต้องการส่งข้อความว่า I love quantum แล้วฉันก็จะเข้ารหัสข้อความ
โดยใช้ one-time pad แบบนี้ ก่อนอื่นเราแปลงตัวอักษรในข้อความของเราเป็น binary ตัวอักษรแต่ละตัว A ถึง Z จะ
สอดคล้องกับตัวเลข 1 ถึง 26 ที่เขียนเป็น binary ดังนั้น A จะเป็น 0, 0
0, 1, B เป็น 0, 0, 1,
0, C เป็น 0, 0, 1, 1 และอื่นๆ
และช่องว่างจะเป็นแค่ศูนย์ทั้งหมด
แล้วนี่คือสิ่งที่ข้อความกลายเป็น เราเข้ารหัสข้อความโดยทำ XOR ระหว่างแต่ละ bit ในข้อความและ
bit ที่สอดคล้องกันใน one-time pad ถ้าคุณยังไม่เคยเห็น XOR มาก่อน
มันย่อมาจาก exclusive or XOR ระหว่างสอง bit จะเป็นหนึ่งถ้ามีเพียง bit
หนึ่งที่เป็นหนึ่ง และศูนย์ถ้าทั้งคู่เป็นศูนย์หรือทั้งคู่เป็นหนึ่ง ดังนั้น ชุดแรกของห้า bit ในข้อความที่เข้ารหัสแล้ว
กลายเป็น 1, 0,
0, 1, 1 ฉันจะเว้นให้คุณทำ XOR ที่เหลือด้วยตัวเอง แต่ประเด็นก็คือ
ข้อความนี้ตอนนี้เป็นแค่ string สุ่มของ 0 และ 1 ที่ไม่มีรูปแบบ มันถอดรหัสไม่ได้เลยสำหรับใครที่
ไม่มี one-time pad ที่เราใช้เข้ารหัสข้อความ ดังนั้น เราเรียนรู้อะไรจนถึงตอนนี้ การเข้ารหัสบาง
scheme ดีกว่าอื่นๆ และบางอย่างสามารถอนุมานได้โดยคนฉลาดที่มองหารูปแบบในข้อความที่เข้ารหัสแล้ว
แต่คีย์สุ่มจริงๆ ที่ shift แต่ละตัวอักษรในข้อความลับด้วยปริมาณสุ่มที่ต่างกัน ไม่สามารถ
อนุมานได้เพราะไม่มีรูปแบบในข้อความ ช่องโหว่เดียวใน scheme แบบนี้คือการมั่นใจว่า
คีย์ที่ใช้เข้ารหัสข้อความไม่ตกไปอยู่ในมือที่ผิด นี่คือจุดที่ quantum key
distribution เข้ามา โดยการใช้ qubit Bennett และ Brassard ได้คิดค้นวิธีให้สองฝ่ายตกลงกันเรื่องคีย์และ
มั่นใจได้อย่างสมเหตุสมผลว่าบุคคลที่สามไม่ได้ดักฟังอยู่เลย BB84 protocol นี้ซับซ้อนนิดหน่อย แต่
เราจะผ่านมันทีละขั้น สำหรับคำอธิบายนี้ ให้เอาเพื่อนเก่าของเราอย่าง Alice และ
Bob มาด้วย Protocol เริ่มด้วย Alice เตรียม qubit ชุดหนึ่งเพื่อส่งให้ Bob qubit เหล่านี้มี
ข้อมูลที่จะกลายเป็น one-time pad หรือคีย์ที่แชร์กัน Alice สร้างลำดับสุ่มสองอันที่
มีความยาวเท่ากันก่อน อันหนึ่งเป็นลำดับสุ่มของ 0 และ 1 และอีกอันเป็นลำดับสุ่มของ x และ z ที่แทน
basis ที่เธอจะเตรียม qubit ของเธอ แล้วเธอจะเตรียม qubit แต่ละตัวใน quantum state ตาม
การรวมกันของ basis และ bit value ที่แสดงในตารางนี้ ดังนั้นถ้า bit เป็นศูนย์และ basis เป็น z เธอจะ
เตรียม qubit ใน zero state หรือถ้า bit เป็นหนึ่งและ basis เป็น X เธอจะเตรียมมันใน minus state ถ้า
ไม่แน่ใจว่า basis และ quantum state เหล่านี้คืออะไร ก็ไม่เป็นไร ประเด็นหลักที่ต้องรู้คือ
การวัดในแต่ละ basis จะมีผลลัพธ์ที่เป็นไปได้แค่สองอย่างเสมอ 0 หรือ 1 สำหรับ Z-basis และบวกหรือลบสำหรับ X
basis ถ้าคุณวัด zero state ใน Z-basis คุณจะได้ศูนย์เสมอ
แต่ถ้าคุณวัดสถานะเดียวกันนั้นใน x basis คุณจะได้ผลสุ่มทั้งบวกหรือลบด้วยโอกาส 50%
แต่ละอย่าง ดังนั้น Alice อาจเตรียม string ของ qubit แบบนี้ โดยที่นี่คือ string สุ่มของ
0 และ 1 และนี่คือ string สุ่มของ x และ z ดังนั้น element แรกในแต่ละลำดับ
สองลำดับของเธอคือ 0 และ x ซึ่งหมายความว่าเธอจะเตรียม qubit ตัวแรกใน plus state และ
อื่นๆ เมื่อเธอเตรียม qubit state ทั้งหมดแล้ว Alice จะส่ง qubit เหล่านั้นให้ Bob และ Bob จะสุ่มเลือกระหว่าง X
และ Z เป็น basis ที่จะวัดแต่ละตัว ดังนั้นเราเพิ่มแถวบางแถวใน
ตารางเพื่อแทนทางเลือกและการวัดของ Bob นี่คือ
การวัดและทางเลือก basis ของ Bob และนี่คือผลการวัดของ qubit ที่ Alice ส่งให้เขา สุดท้าย Bob
สามารถแปลงการวัดแต่ละอย่างเป็น bit โดยใช้ตารางเดียวกับที่ Alice ใช้เตรียม qubit ของเธอ เมื่อเขาวัด
zero หรือ plus state เขากำหนด bit value ศูนย์ และเมื่อเขาวัด one หรือ minus state เขาใส่ค่า
หนึ่ง ดังนั้น bit string สุดท้ายของ Bob คือแถวสุดท้ายนี้
สังเกตว่าเมื่อ basis ของขั้นตอนการเตรียมของ Alice และขั้นตอนการวัดของ Bob ตรงกัน bit ของพวกเขาก็จะตรงกัน
ด้วย แต่ถ้า Alice เลือกเตรียม Z และ Bob วัดใน X หรือในทางกลับกัน
แล้ว bit ที่สอดคล้องกันของ Alice และ Bob ก็จะไม่จำเป็นต้องเหมือนกัน ดังนั้น วิธีที่พวกเขาทั้งสองตกลงกันเรื่อง bit string
สำหรับ one-time pad คือโทรหากันและบอกกันว่าพวกเขาใช้ basis ไหนสำหรับ qubit แต่ละตัว
เมื่อ basis ตรงกัน พวกเขาเก็บ bit ไว้ และเมื่อไม่ตรงกัน พวกเขาทิ้งมัน
ดังนั้น ในกรณีนี้ Alice และ Bob จะตกลงกันเรื่อง bit string ของ 0, 0, 1, 0,
0 แล้วระบบนี้ป้องกันการดักฟังที่ไม่ถูกตรวจจับได้ยังไง มาดูว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นเมื่อคนดักฟังที่เรียกว่า
Eve ดักจับ qubit ที่ Alice ส่งให้ Bob เธอไม่รู้ว่า qubit เหล่านี้อยู่ในสถานะไหนหรือ
Alice เตรียมมันยังไง ดังนั้น ต้องขอบคุณ uncertainty principle และสิ่งที่เรียกว่า no-cloning theorem เธอไม่สามารถ
แค่ทำสำเนา qubit ที่เหมือนกันเพื่อส่งต่อให้ Bob ถ้าเธอทำได้ เธอก็สามารถ
ดักฟังโดยไม่ถูกตรวจจับ แต่แทนที่จะทำอย่างนั้น เธอเดา basis ที่จะวัด qubit แต่ละตัว วัดพวกมัน แล้วก็
เตรียม qubit ปลอม ชุดใหม่เพื่อส่งต่อให้ Bob มีวิธีแอบซ่อนอื่นๆ ที่ Eve อาจลอง
เพื่อเรียนรู้เกี่ยวกับ qubit แต่ไม่มีวิธีไหนที่จะหลีกเลี่ยง uncertainty principle ได้
ดังนั้น เราจะสมมติว่า Eve ดักฟังด้วยวิธีตรงๆ นี้ นี่คือตารางที่อธิบาย
การเตรียมของ Alice การดักจับของ Eve และการวัดสุดท้ายของ Bob ดังนั้นตอนนี้เมื่อ
Alice และ Bob คุยโทรศัพท์เพื่อเปรียบเทียบ basis ของพวกเขา พวกเขาจะตัดสินใจเก็บ bit เหล่านี้สำหรับคีย์ของพวกเขา แต่
bit ไม่ตรงกัน เพราะ Bob กำลังวัด qubit ที่ Eve เตรียม ไม่ใช่ qubit เดิมที่ Alice มี
ถ้าพวกเขาเปรียบเทียบ bit subset ใน bit string ของพวกเขากัน พวกเขาจะเห็นว่าบางตัวไม่ตรงกันและ
สรุปว่าต้องมีคนดักฟัง เนื่องจาก Eve ถูกพบ Alice และ Bob จะทิ้ง
bit string ของพวกเขาและเริ่ม protocol ใหม่ทั้งหมด แต่ถ้า Eve ไม่ได้ดักฟัง และ subset ของ
bit ที่ Alice และ Bob เปรียบเทียบตรงกัน พวกเขาก็สามารถใช้ bit ที่เหลือที่ไม่ได้
เปรียบเทียบเป็นคีย์ที่แชร์กันได้ เมื่อ Alice และ Bob มีคีย์ที่แชร์กันแล้ว Alice สามารถส่งข้อความที่เข้ารหัสให้ Bob ได้ และ
Bob เป็นคนเดียวที่สามารถถอดรหัสได้โดยใช้คีย์ ตอนนี้ที่เราผ่าน protocol มาแล้ว มาลองทำมันบน
คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมกัน มีสองสิ่งที่ต้องจำไว้สำหรับการทดลองนี้ ประการแรก
BB84 มีประโยชน์จริงๆ ก็ต่อเมื่อ Alice และ Bob อยู่ห่างกัน สำหรับการทดลองที่เราจะทำ Alice
และ Bob อยู่บน quantum chip เดียวกัน ดังนั้น การทดลองนี้จะไม่มีประโยชน์สำหรับการแลกเปลี่ยนข้อมูลส่วนตัว แต่มัน
ยังคงเป็นการสาธิตเชิงแนวคิดที่ดีของ BB84
ประการที่สอง คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมจริงๆ มี noise ดังนั้น แม้ว่า basis การเตรียมของ Alice ตรงกับ basis การวัดของ Bob
และไม่มีคนดักฟัง ยังคงมีโอกาสน้อยที่พวกเขาจะวัดได้ bit ต่างกันเนื่องจาก error ใน
คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม เมื่อพวกเขาเปรียบเทียบ bit string เพื่อตรวจสอบคนดักฟัง พวกเขาต้องมีความอดทนต่อ error บ้างก่อนที่พวกเขาจะ
สรุปว่าต้องมีคนดักฟังมายุ่งและทิ้งคีย์ทั้งหมด ตอนนี้ที่มีข้อแม้เหล่านั้นแล้ว
มาเริ่มด้วยการทดลองที่ไม่มีคนดักฟัง ก่อนอื่น เราสุ่ม
สร้าง bit string สามอันที่แตกต่างกัน แต่ละอันมี 20 bits อันแรกคือ bit string เริ่มต้นของ Alice
อันที่สองคือรายการ basis ที่ Alice จะเตรียม qubit ของเธอ
เราเลือกใช้ศูนย์แทน Z basis และหนึ่งแทน X basis รายการสุดท้ายคือ basis ที่
Bob จะวัด qubit แต่ละตัว จาก list สามอันนั้น เราสามารถสร้าง circuit diagram ที่มีคำสั่งสำหรับ
การเตรียมของ Alice และการวัดของ Bob qubit ทั้งหมดเริ่มต้นใน zero state ดังนั้นในการเตรียม qubit ของเธอใน
Z basis Alice จะไม่ทำอะไรเลยสำหรับ zero state หรือใช้ NOT หรือ X gate ที่แสดงเป็นกล่องสีน้ำเงินที่มีป้าย X
สำหรับ one state เพื่อเตรียมใน X basis เธอใช้ Hadamard gate ที่นำ zero ไปยัง plus state
หรือ NOT gate ตามด้วย Hadamard เพื่อเตรียม minus state แล้วเธอส่ง qubit ให้ Bob กล่องถัดไปชุดหนึ่ง
ใน circuit แทนการวัดของ Bob เพื่อวัดใน Z basis เขาไม่จำเป็นต้องใช้ gate เพิ่มเติม
เขาแค่วัด ซึ่งแสดงด้วยกล่องสีเทาเหล่านี้ เพื่อวัดใน X basis เขาใช้ Hadamard ก่อน
แล้วจึงวัด เราจะรัน circuit นี้โดยใช้ Qiskit runtime primitive sampler และ output คือ bit
string การวัดของ Bob แล้วเราสามารถเปรียบเทียบ bit string ของ Bob กับ bit string เริ่มต้นของ Alice โดยทิ้ง bit
ที่ basis ไม่ตรงกัน และเราเห็นว่าพวกเขาทั้งสองได้คีย์เดียวกัน
จำไว้ว่านี่คือ hardware จริงๆ ดังนั้นบางครั้งอาจมี bit ที่ควรตรงกันแต่ไม่ตรง ในกรณีนี้
bit ทั้งหมดตรงกัน แต่ถ้าคุณรันอีกครั้งด้วยตัวเอง อาจมี error เกิดขึ้น แต่ตราบใดที่ fidelity ใกล้เคียงกับหนึ่ง
Alice และ Bob สามารถมั่นใจได้อย่างสมเหตุสมผลว่าไม่มีคนดักฟัง ตอนนี้มาดูว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นถ้า Eve ดักจับ
qubit ตอนนี้เรามีสอง circuit อันแรกแสดงการเตรียมของ Alice และการดักจับและ
การวัดของ Eve อันถัดไปแสดงการเตรียม qubit ปลอมของ Eve และการวัดของ Bob เรา
สามารถรัน circuit เหล่านี้เหมือนเดิม แล้วดูว่า Alice และ Bob จะได้อะไรเมื่อพวกเขาเปรียบเทียบ bit
string ของพวกเขา คราวนี้พวกเขาได้ fidelity ประมาณ 2/3 สิ่งนี้ต่ำกว่า
ที่จะอธิบายได้ด้วย noise ในคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมมาก ดังนั้นพวกเขาสรุปว่า Eve กำลังดักฟัง การคำนวณควอนตัมเป็น
สิ่งที่รู้จักกันดีและมักถูก hype สำหรับศักยภาพในการแก้ปัญหายาก แต่การสื่อสารและการเข้ารหัสควอนตัม
มักได้รับความสนใจน้อยกว่ามาก ทั้งที่ศักยภาพที่ควอนตัมสามารถให้ในพื้นที่เหล่านี้มีความสำคัญ
และน่าตื่นเต้นพอๆ กัน วันนี้เราพูดถึง protocol ที่ค้นพบแรกที่สุดสำหรับ quantum key distribution ซึ่ง
แทบจะต้านทานการดักฟังที่ไม่ถูกตรวจจับได้ ถ้าอยากลองส่งรหัสที่ถอดไม่ได้
ด้วยคีย์ที่รับรองด้วยควอนตัม ไปที่ module ที่ลิงก์ในคำอธิบายได้เลย
ขอบคุณที่ดู แล้วเจอกันครั้งหน้า